every democrat in the world declares for
2020 antisemites pay tribute to the
holocaust and twitter decides that
maybe we shouldn't tell journalists who
are unemployed to learn to code i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
well i hope you had a wonderful relaxing
weekend i did until both my kids came
down
with 103 degree fevers because that's
the way being a parent is it's fantastic
except when it sucks
we'll get to the news in just one second
but first let's talk about how you can
make your company
more efficient how by getting better
employees of course i mean look at the
schlubs around you you need ziprecruiter
hiring can be pretty time consuming you
post a job to several online job boards
only to get tons of the wrong resumes
then you have to sort through all of the
resumes just to find a few people with
the right skills and experience
those job sites that overwhelm you with
the wrong resumes are not smart which is
why you should be using ziprecruiter.com
dailywire unlike other job sites
ziprecruiter finds qualified candidates
for you
it's powerful matching technology scans
thousands of resumes to identify people
with the right skills education and
experience and then actively invites
them to apply to your job
so you get qualified candidates fast
it's no wonder zip recruiter is rated
number one by employers in the united
states
that rating comes from hiring sites on
trustpilot with over 1 000 reviews right
now
my listeners can try ziprecruiter for
free at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com dailywire we use zip
recruiter here at the daily wire
and you should use it at your own
business if you love the show show your
support for the show and zip recruiter
by going to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that ziprecruiter.com
dailywire d-a-i-l-y w-ire zip recruiter
the smartest
way to hire all right so we begin today
with the big announcement
oh i know everyone in california was
waiting for it just
so excited about our garbage attorney
general
kamala harris our garbage center kamala
harris deciding
that she was going to run for president
of the united states who's all super
exciting
because she's basically like hillary
clinton except even more intersectional
which is just amazing so she gave her
opening speech her i'm going to run for
president speech
based on zero actual accomplishments in
office
she's been senator for about five
minutes so she's following the barack
obama
path to glory kamala harris's career as
a senator has
been shall we say testy and she spent
most of the kavanaugh hearings
suggesting
that religious people were terrible and
also that brett kavanaugh as a gang
rapist that seems like a great platform
to run on a unifying
a unifying theme so kamala harris
announced yesterday in oakland number
one
important to know she should do a big
crowd in oakland that's not that hard to
do for people like kamala harris and i'm
not talking about
her race i'm talking about the fact that
if you are a lefty in oakland donald
trump won five percent of the vote in
oakland
in 2016. five percent she was introduced
by libby schaff for people who don't
remember the oakland mayor
libby schaff libby schaff is such a
leftist she's such a crazy leftist that
she actually
probably obstructed justice when she
informed illegal immigrants in her own
city of an upcoming ice raid
in february chef issued a public warning
for the immigrant communities in her
city
that u.s immigrations and customs
enforcement agents in san francisco
were going to be engaging in raids of
illegal immigrant criminals so she
warned criminals and they all escaped
she was the person who decided to
introduce kamala harris
so that's where kamala harris is kamal
harris is a very very far-left character
she's masquerading
as a of the road character so that she
can get ahead
in these primaries now she has some
advantages a lot of the other democratic
candidates don't
and if you had to handicap the race
right now you would think that she would
have a pretty heavy advantage number one
she checks two intersectional boxes
she's a woman and she is black
a heavy dose of the democratic base is
black about 30
of the democratic primary base in 2008
was black that's what allowed barack
obama to defeat
hillary clinton despite the fact that i
believe in the end she won more popular
votes in the primaries
than he did while kamala harris is going
to have
i think some of those same advantages
because she is the only black candidate
who has yet declared
running for president she also has the
advantage of tremendous media coverage
the media
love her and the media love her
specifically because they think that she
is obama part two we had obama part one
with obama and now we're gonna get obama
part two
with kamala harris she's more attractive
than hillary clinton just physically
attractive than hillary clinton and so
that's going to help her out i'm not
saying that barack obama's saying that
barack obama in 2013 labeled her what
was it the hottest
attorney general in the country he was
not labeled as sexist for that by the
way which is
fascinating and more than that kamala
harris touches all the various aspects
of the democratic base that need to be
touched so she's got a foot in sort of
the moderate camp because she's not as
wild and crazy and out there as
elizabeth warren and bernie sanders at
least overtly
she is privately she touches in
she touches on the intersectional camp
she touches a little bit on the
millennial camp not as much as people
like beta o'rourke or maybe even bernie
but she's she's probably the most
well-rounded democratic candidate
just in terms of who she can reach out
and and touch
she also has an inherent advantage
because of her race so if she wants to
reach out to black folks she does not
actually need
to play the pandering game now what
you'll see from all the other democratic
candidates who have declared today is
that they are indeed playing a pandering
game
where they do this routine or they go
out there and they talk about racism a
lot
and the problem for them is that by
doing that what they actually do is
they they push people away during a
general election kamala harris
because she is who she is doesn't have
to talk about racial polarization
all that much people sort of assume that
she understands the issue because of her
race and so that gives her
the ability to just simply go over the
top
and not talk about the racial issue as
much barack obama did much of the same
thing in 2008 all right so she kicked
off
her presidential campaign with about
apparently 20 000 people
showing up in oakland and she did it
speaking against
city hall so i'm not even sure how she
got a license to do that but she did it
again city hall so it looked like a
presidential
address and she quoted bobby kennedy
because we will never escape the baby
boomers she said these are not ordinary
times and this will not be
an ordinary election she then threw out
a bunch of platitudes
although she dropped a few she dropped a
few kind of new
twists like for example she talked about
transphobia which i'm sure is going to
be a massive winner
across the country in the general
election she also stressed her
experience prosecuting sex crimes
and fighting transnational gangs now the
funny part about this is that she was a
terrible attorney general
i mean she was such a bad attorney
general that she was roundly criticized
by law enforcement for her
for her general failures to defend law
enforcement in fact
she that there was one particular case
where illegal immigrants
killed a killed in a law enforcement
officer and she refused to
take a harsh enough stance against
illegal immigration and that led a lot
of law enforcement officials
to come after her and criticize her for
a good reason
on the left there a lot of people who
criticize kamala harris because they
feel that she was too harsh they feel
that she was too willing to put people
in jail particularly for drug crimes in
any case here was kamala harris
announcing her run
yesterday in oakland we are here
at this moment in time because we must
answer
a fundamental question who
are we who are we
as americans so
let's answer that question to the world
and each other right here
and right now america
we are better than this
so i mean that's some pretty boring
stuff right there she's not an inspiring
speaker by any stretch of the
imagination she's
she's pretty charisma-free but that's
not going to hurt her
all that much because again we're going
to get the the media's favorite thing
which is she's the first
right so barack obama was the first
black president now we're going to have
the first female black president
and then in eight years we will have the
first female black
little person of native american
heritage who is transgender as president
it'll be very exciting when that happens
then harris who is a radical leftist she
says i'm running to be president of the
people okay this is just a lie she's
running to be president of democrats
again
this is a lady who has insulted
catholics suggested that catholics don't
belong on federal courts this is a lady
who has suggested that brett kavanaugh
was a gang rapist this is a woman
who was so bad at representing the
people of california when the people of
california voted in favor of traditional
marriage
and then there was a lawsuit on the
basis of that vote
she refused his california attorney
general to represent the people
right this was actually an issue it went
to the ninth circuit court of appeals in
the ninth circuit court of appeals on
the basis of kamala harris alone
deciding that she was not going to stand
up
for the vote of the californian people
they decided they weren't even going to
take up the case and they would strike
down proposition 8 but here she is
pretending to be
a uniter rather than a divider i'm
running
for president because i love
my country i love my country
i'm running to be president of the
people
by the people and for all people
okay well again no that's not a thing
that that's happening
and the way you can tell this is because
even in the midst of her speech
she started dropping all sorts of
alienating language so here she was
yesterday explaining
that in her fights against transnational
gangs a wall won't work we can't we
can't have a wall
obviously what we need instead is the
sanctuary city policy that she herself
supports
for the people meant fighting
transnational gangs through trafficking
drugs and guns and human beings and i
saw their sophistication
their persistence and their ruthlessness
and folks on the subject of
transnational gangs let's be perfectly
clear
the president's medieval vanity project
is not going to stop them okay you know
probably won't stop them
either by the way is her sanctuary city
policy again the person who introduced
her here was libby schaff
the oakland mayor who legitimately
warned criminal gang members
that ice was going to come raid the city
so if you if you feel safe with kamala
harris let me tell you as a resident of
california
crime rates rose under kamala harris
when she was attorney general out here
okay the crime was not great under her
she did not do a good job
it doesn't matter she's going to be
touted by the media anyway and
why does she have such a bad
relationship with law enforcement
because she like barack obama like much
of the democratic party
spends an awful lot of time suggesting
that the police are basically racist
i'm running to fight for an america
where no mother or father
has to teach their young son that people
may
stop him arrest him
chase him or kill him because of his
race
okay this is such a slander against law
enforcement it's such a slander against
law enforcement that law enforcement
officials are running around shooting
black people because of their race it's
just a lie there is no statistical
evidence to support that whatsoever
that there is a wild racial
discrimination problem in police
departments
across the country that results in
police officers shooting black people
simply because of their race there's a
myth that was pushed by the obama
administration it is simply not true
by every statistic i have ever seen this
is simply not true
okay particularly when you're talking
about people being shot if you want to
make the case that police
treat black folks disproportionately in
terms of
roughing them up during arrests there's
some evidence to to back that
up there was a harvard study by roland
fryer that suggested that maybe that was
the case but when it comes to the idea
that police are disproportionately
overall racist and are going after black
folks
because of race again no evidence of
this but look she's a radical and the
media love this now
she does have a pretty big problem with
her resume and i'm going to explain this
in just one second
but first let's talk about birthdays
anniversaries valentine's days these
things these things are just around the
corner so
when you are looking for the biggest and
best quality roses out there you need to
talk to my friends at 1 800 flowers dot
com
right now you can get 18 red roses for
29.99 or
upgrade to 24 red roses for 10 bucks
more this is a fantastic offer from 1
800 flowers i've been using 1 800
flowers for years i mean every time i'm
on the road i send my wife flowers
because that's just the kind of husband
i am but you can also be a great husband
be a great partner
18 red roses for 29.99 or upgrade to 24
red roses for 10 bucks more
it makes it easy to shop the quality is
fantastic it's better than anything
you're going to get at the local grocery
store
roses from 1 800 flowers are picked at
their peak and they're shipped overnight
to ensure freshness and her amazement 18
red roses for 29.99 or upgrade again
to 24 red roses for 10 bucks more it's
the perfect reward for thinking ahead
and ordering early bouquet prices will
indeed be going up soon so you do want
to order early
pick your delivery date 1 800 flowers
handles all of the rest
i don't settle for anything less than 1
800 flowers when i'm buying my white
flowers to order 18 red roses for 29.99
or upgrade to 24 red roses for only 10
bucks more go to 1 800 flowers dot com
shapiro that's 1 800 flowers dot com
shapiro hurry that offer expires
wednesday go check it out right now 1800
flowers.com
shapiro for that special deal they're
really great okay so
what is the big problem for kamala
harris well the biggest problem for
kamala harris is she's utterly
unqualified
right she's utterly unqualified for this
office again she was not a good attorney
general of the state of california she's
a terrible senator from the state of
california
and the way she got started if she'd
gotten started if any republican woman
had gotten started in politics the way
kamala harris got started in politics
she would be a laughingstock off the bat
she would be a laughingstock
what am i talking about i'm talking
about willie brown so for folks who
don't know california politics
willie brown is the former leader of
basically the democratic caucus
across the state of california a very
powerful man in california politics
well willie brown has been married for
many many years and there's one
problem with that which is that he has
also dated
half of the women in california while he
was married
yeah he's a bit of a douche bag brown
served as san francisco mayor from 1996
until january
2002 2004 and
he was considered a very very powerful
democrat
across the state he was succeeded by
gavin newsom there was a
he was sort of associated with arnold
schwarzenegger a little bit
in any case when he was 60 years old
willie brown met kamala harris
he was married at the time and kamala
harris who was 30 started dating him i'm
sure it was just a partnership of love
i'm sure they fell in love at first
sight i'm sure that she looked at him
and she thought
60 year old is so attractive 60 year old
man twice my age
that's that's the i love him that's
that's what's going to happen here
or alternatively or alternatively and
this is not cynical
this is just the fact he gave her a
bunch of jobs how do i know he gave her
a bunch of jobs
because he says so in an editorial for
the set
for the san francisco chronicle today
hey here's what he writes
i've been peppered with calls from the
national media about my relationship
with kamala harris
particularly since it became obvious
that she was going to run for president
most of them i have not returned
yes we dated it was more than 20 years
ago he was married at the time
he was 60 she was 30. yes i may have
influenced her career by appointing her
to two state commissions
when i was assembly speaker first of all
that's just an outright admission of
corruption
that you were nailing somebody and so
you appointed them to state commissions
when you were assembly speaker
like how is that okay i'm wondering how
is that not just blatant corruption
of course it is blatant corruption by
the way both of those both of those jobs
were near six-figure salaries for
nothing for doing nothing
except for presumably dating a married
man and then he says i certainly helped
her with her first race for district
attorney in san francisco
i've also helped the careers of nancy
pelosi gavin newsom dianne feinstein and
a host of other politicians oh really
did you date them also
i missed the part where you were dating
gavin newsom i missed the part where you
were dating him
and presumably enjoying each other and
then you decided that you were going to
help gavin newsom with his mayoral run
missed that part he says the difference
is that harris is the only one
who after i helped her sent word that i
would be indicted if i so much as
jaywalked while
she while she was d.a right because she
has to say that because if she doesn't
say that then it looks like open
corruption
because that's politics for you wow just
just amazing stuff in a second i'm going
to explain why
nobody in the media is going to pay
attention they're going to call it
sexist if you mention
this story right if you mention the
story it's okay so
the media are going to say that willie
brown did something terrible by
mentioning this
except for the fact that again if any
republican ever had done anything like
this they would be a laughing stock
let's say that let's say for example
that sarah palin
when she was selected for vice president
it had come out that
she dated george h.w bush while he was
married to barbara
and that he made sure that she got her
start in alaska politics you think that
might have been a bit of an issue for
her for her vp run
you think or no if it turned out that
nikki haley for example
had gotten into politics by dating a man
twice her age who then gave her
political favors you might think that'd
be used as a club by the media
yeah i think so unless you think that
this is a sexist thing
it is not you know how many times i have
mocked john kerry
john carr former 2004 candidate and
secretary of state
i marked him one million times for
having married terresa
he married one rich woman and then
divorced her and then married another
rich woman and then lived off her
fortune
it was always seen and it should be seen
as a bad thing in american politics
to marry for political purposes this was
the rip on hillary clinton too by the
way
is that she lived off her husband's name
and lived off of his coattails
so that she could then run for senator
and president and be secretary of state
kamala harris is not a feminist icon if
she was dating willie brown so she could
get appointed
to a bunch of positions while he was
married by the way i know that we i know
we gloss over this in american life now
and on both sides in both political
parties we have ignored the idea that
adultery is bad
i know that republicans now think oh
well you know it happens because
president trump and i know the democrats
do that have been doing this routine for
literally decades that since
the era of jfk whatever so they commit
adultery it's kind of bad
when you are the other woman to a
married man who is then providing you
with giveaway jobs in the california
state government
that's kind of bad now nobody's going to
attack her on this because if other
democrats do then she will claim sexism
president trump might because
president trump has no limits one of the
beautiful things about the man is that
he will say anything at any time
but should that be an issue of course
that should be an issue it is obvious
overt corruption and she should have to
answer questions about that
and she shouldn't be able to shy away
with answers like oh yeah i felt deeply
in love with willie brown when he was 60
and i was 30.
eh yeah that's that's a thing that
happens all the time
and there are lots of six-year-old men
you know how many of them who are you
know kind of middle-class schlubs
who aren't powerful men in politics are
getting 30 year old
up-and-coming lawsuit and girlfriends
tons of them tons just it happens all
the time
and meanwhile it's not just kamala
harris who's jumping into the pool
it's also elizabeth warren now elizabeth
warren is going to campaign as an open
communist i'm old enough to remember
when elizabeth warren was writing books
like the two income trap all about how
the middle class in the united states
was suffering
and how school vouchers for example
could be a solution
for some of these families well now
she's decided to steal bernie sanders
audience by going overtly kami
and the new york times is praising her
for it so here's what she tweeted out
over the weekend
did elizabeth warren this billionaire
nfl owner just paid a hundred million
dollars
for a super yacht with its own imax
theater i'm pretty sure he can pay my
new ultra
millionaire tax to help the millions of
yachtless americans struggling with
student loan debt
this is reference to dan snyder who's
the owner of the redskins
well elizabeth warren might have a
problem with the owner of the redskins
in any case i i do love the the the
overt communism of this is pretty
astonishing
so is there any allegation that dan
snyder did not pay his taxes
no he paid his taxes as far as i know is
there anything wrong with him buying a
giant yacht
which presumably employed lots and lots
of people to build
i love the idea from a lot of folks on
the left that when you spend money on a
product there's no one on the other end
of that product ooh he spent money on a
yacht
you know how many people made that yacht
if it cost 100 million dollars i thought
you guys are in favor of spending i
thought you liked spending over saving
so shouldn't you be in favor of him
spending a hundred million dollars on a
yacht
as opposed to simply putting it into his
bank account
but i guess that if you if you buy
something that is excessively expensive
then elizabeth warren will come after
you by the way elizabeth warren is worth
something like 15 to 18 million
herself so she can start giving away her
cash any time she damn well pleases
what's hilarious to me is the way that
the media treat all of these candidates
so they'll treat kamala harris with kid
gloves even though
again a married man is openly relating
in prince how he dated her and then
corruptly gave her jobs
elizabeth warren is one of the more
charmless candidates in the 2020 race
and there's a piece in the new york
times called elizabeth warren's 21 2020
strategy
stand out by nerding out now it is
incredible when's the last time you
heard
a republican referred to as a nerd by
the new york times
like maybe they'll do it every so often
with somebody like ben sasse or
something because they have a book
review
but when is the last time you heard an
actual political candidate for us like
ted cruz
called the nerd by the new york times
usually they are considered charmless
manipulators
right they never call them nerds if a
republican fails to connect to people
that's because that republican is cold
and calculating and machiavellian
when a democrat fails to connect to the
people it's because they're just
too smart al gore was just
too smart sure he wasn't smart enough
not to tell a masseuse to go after his
third chakra
but he was really really smart john
kerry
sure he wasn't smart enough to get into
harvard law school after going to
harvard undergrad he ended up at bu
which is not a great recommendation for
his intellect but
john kerry super he couldn't connect
with the people he was just so
smart hillary clinton just so brilliant
so brilliant but she couldn't that's why
she couldn't connect to humans because
she's like a whiz in there and just so
many brains
now they're doing the same thing with
elizabeth warren so here is the new york
times the objective
unbiased new york times the gym was hot
the lights malfunctioned but the
audience of nearly 1 000 people was
engrossed
as senator elizabeth warren the
massachusetts democrat and presidential
hopeful did what she does best
nerd out as she puts it why just carry
around a drool bucket
people after talking up gun control laws
and criminal justice reform
on a recent south carolina campaign
swing ms warren dug into the
nitty-gritty of free market regulation
and a consumer financial protection
bureau a federal agency she helped
create which has returned more than 12
billion dollars to people in refunds and
cancelled debts
nothing made her more enthusiastic by
the end she had many in the audience
cheering
okay now remember this is not just like
a regular audience they came up to see
elizabeth warren
it's like if you buy a pr if you buy a
ticket to a broadway production these
days
you will never go to a broadway
production that does not really receive
a standing ovation at the end
why because if you drop 100 bucks on a
ticket you want to make yourself feel
that you actually did it for something
worthwhile so you give a standing
ovation if you drive out to see
elizabeth warren on a school night
you got to give her a standing o at the
end so you feel like you did something
useful with your time
almost one month into her presidential
campaign says the new york times
miss warren's passion for policy minutia
has become her way of standing out
in an increasingly crowded democratic
field establish
establishing herself as a wonks wonk
whose expansive ideas
and detail-oriented speaking style are
her bid for a good
first impression on voters wow she's
just so brilliant
she's so brilliant in a second i'm gonna
read you some more of this and we'll get
into the other democrats
who have jumped into the race
legitimately everyone on earth
we'll get to howard schultz too in just
a second first let me remind you
that the best present that you can get
for a parent
or loved one these days legacy box why
well because legacy box helps you
preserve all those memories
my wife and i we were looking through
our pictures the other day and we
thought to ourselves we have so many
digital pictures but
how many of them do we have printed out
and then we have a bunch of old pictures
since before we had digital cameras i
know we're that old
right where we actually took pictures
like film what happens
if those should be in a flood or
something well this is where legacy box
comes in it's particularly true if you
have older
film if you have vhs tapes all that
stuff's out mold ring in the garage well
you need legacy box
what legacy box does is it saves your
family films and photos from being
degraded or lost forever
you take all of these old home movies
and pictures and then you send it in
to legacy box and they do the rest they
professionally digitize your moments
onto a thumb drive digital download or
dvd
they have easy to follow instructions
and safety barcodes including for every
item receive all your original recorded
moments back along with perfectly
preserved
digital copies get personalized updates
and every step receives up to 12
personalized email updates all
the way along the line so you know
what's happening with your materials
over 450
000 families have trusted legacy box
instead of you having all of this stuff
in the garage you're never going to look
at it again now you've got it all
on a handy thumb drive so if god forbid
there's a fire you can run and also you
got it everywhere you need to be which
is awesome there's never been a better
time to digitally preserve your memories
go check out legacybox.com today to get
started honestly your life is your
memories you're not going to want to
miss this go check it out
legacybox.com ben when you use that
slash ben
you get 40 off your first order that's
legacybox.com
ben's get 40 off your first order
legacybox.com save 40
today go check it out right now all
right so the new york times praising
elizabeth warren
listen to the description of the various
candidates so they say that she has
expansive ideas and a detail-oriented
speaking style
aka she's boring and then they say that
kamala harris focuses on sweeping themes
of unity and change that ms warren is
making a personal and political wager
that audiences care more about policy
savvy than captivating oration which is
her saying basically i'm incredibly
boring but let me just talk to you
about my garbage tax ideas
so that is the way the new york times is
positioning elizabeth warren very very
exciting stuff she's a nerd she's a nerd
and then
there's senator bernie sanders so he is
also considering running for president
now
he says that he is set to announce his
2020 presidential
run two sources with direct knowledge of
his plans told yahoo news that sanders
an independent and self-described
democratic socialist plans to announce
his presidential bid imminently in the
latest polls by the way the poll that i
the most recent poll that i saw i
believe is a political poll and what it
showed
was biden up front with 26 bernie with
like 16
kamala harris with nine everybody else
with five so
sanders is still a presence in the race
he's still
charming to millennials for some for the
same reason that like old people
at the at the old age home are sometimes
charming to young people
you know he's kind of like a fun uncle
he's like a fun uncle sure he says
kooky things about venezuelan
dictatorship but he's kind of kooky
he's kind of cookie so sanders is is
going to jump in
as well you could actually actually see
a brokered convention
honestly like there's so many candidates
right now that if the vote splits eight
ways from sunday
and the super delegates don't actually
get to have an impact on the democratic
race this time
what you could see is 83 candidates all
running
and maybe two or three who are viable as
a presidential account now i don't think
that's going to happen i think that
if you have to handicap the race right
now then you put kamala harris probably
near the top
again because she's the best around the
candidate and then maybe joe biden or
bernie sanders
after that joe biden wants to jump in
two biden
is doing exactly what i suggested
earlier in the show joe biden
wants to appeal to minority americans he
knows that the only way he wins the
primaries if he gets black folks to vote
for him well now he's got a challenge
because kamala harris is in the race
so here he is talking about racism
joseph r mcbiden
the same guy who once said that all
people who run 7-elevens are indian
you see and who said that mitt romney
wants to put black people back in chains
here's joe biden going off on race
the bottom line is we have a lot to root
out
but most of all there's systematic
racism that most of us whites don't like
to acknowledge even exist
we don't even consciously acknowledge it
but it's been built into every aspect of
our system
white america has to admit there's still
a systematic racism
and it goes almost unnoticed by so many
of us
super weird how that systematic racism
magically disappeared for like eight
years there
and then now it's back boom check that
stuff out whoa
where'd that racism come from oh it came
from
people didn't elect democrats so all the
racism is back
even hillary clinton is still thinking
about running now hillary would not win
the nomination
because democrats do not want this again
they just don't
but would she be at the top of the polls
initially yeah she would
okay apparently according to cnn white
house correspondent jeff delaney
he said on sunday that clinton told
people as recently as this week she
isn't closing the doors
to the idea of running in 2020 according
to zelane i'm told by three people that
as recently as this week she was telling
people that look
given all this news from the indictments
particularly the roger stone indictment
she talked to several people saying look
i'm not closing the doors to this it
doesn't mean there's a campaign in
waiting or a plan
in the works she said last october she
would still like to be president
by the way if she ran again against
president trump i am not certain she
doesn't win
not because she is better at campaigning
but simply because the reason she lost
last time is because people assumed she
was going to win and she's deeply
unlikable well she's still deeply
unlikable but they're going to be a lot
of hillary revenge voters out there
here's the problem for democrats they
have so many people running that you
could see an incredibly fractious
primary and that's exactly what
republicans are hoping for
it's one of the reasons why they've
closed the doors to the possibility of a
strong primary run
inside their own party they're hoping if
republicans consolidate around trump
early and democrats savage each other
that that will end up dividing the party
what's kind of surprising is that a lot
of republicans are also apparently
negative on howard schultz running so
howard schultz
is the ceo of starbucks the former ceo
of starbucks i think he stepped down
recently
and he announced on 60 minutes that he
might run for president now
he is just he is just what the radical
left is looking for
an older white guy who's a billionaire
and head of a corporation
i know i know it's just what people have
been looking for but if he runs the
moderate
he could take votes away from a radical
left candidate in the democratic party
so here is howard schultz expressing his
wish to run
do you worry that you're going to siphon
votes away from the democrats and
thereby
ensure that president trump has a second
term
i want to see the american people win i
want to see america win
i don't care if you're democrat
independent libertarian
republican bring me your ideas and i
will be
an independent person who will embrace
those ideas
okay first of all what i love is the
democrats have gone nuts over this
how many democrats are actually going to
vote for howard schultz the same number
of republicans who are going to vote for
michael bloomberg okay it's a very
limited number of folks
but you're seeing democrats go off the
wall about this because they are afraid
that somebody will come in and split the
vote again they think that the
libertarian vote is what won
donald trump the presidency jill stein's
vote they think that one donald trump
the presidency in 2016. so they are
deeply afraid of howard schultz running
and this has led a lot of democrats to
attack howard schultz now if you're
trump you got to be sitting there going
okay fine
good schultz is a lefty let him run but
unfortunately president trump has
the habit of immediately dumping on
whoever else jumps into
the race so he tweeted out this morning
howard schultz doesn't have the guts to
run for president watched him on 60
minutes last night and i agree with him
that he is not the smartest
person besides america already has that
i only hope that starbucks is still
paying me their rent in trump tower
a lot going on here so many things going
on first of all mr president schultz is
not a threat to you he's a threat to the
democrats
stop it you want howard schultz to run
you want him to split the vote that is
your goal
second of all i just love that trump
declares himself openly the smartest
person
you have to love that i know lots and
lots of really smart people
you know how many of them going to go
around telling everybody how smart they
are
like on a regular basis the thing about
smart people is they know they're
usually not the smartest person in the
room
i mean i know people who have incredibly
high iqs and when i'm in the room with
them
they are they're they're smarter than i
but
they don't go around talking about it
right it's it's it's just it's amazing
stuff you got you got to love that the
president that's a man with confidence
right there okay in a second
i want to get to holocaust memorial day
and the left's reaction to holocaust
memorial day
but first you need to subscribe for 9.99
a month you can subscribe to the show
that means you get the rest of the show
live also
two additional hours live of this show
later today
why would you miss that why would you
have thousands of people watching behind
the paywall and
asking me questions during the breaks
it's going to be awesome go check that
out also tomorrow
we have daily wire backstage why i don't
know but you should come
daily wire god king jeremy boring me
andrew clavin the excremental michael
knowles and alicia krauss will be here
discussing all the important issues and
of course answering your questions
i know why originally we were going to
do this as a state of the union daily
wire backstage
and then nancy pelosi canceled it and so
we're still doing it we'll be here
anyway tomorrow night so you're going to
want to be here with us because
if i have to suffer with these people
you should too as always only daily wire
subscribers get to ask those questions
so make sure to subscribe today go check
it out we have all sorts of goodies
behind the paywall
also make sure you subscribe at youtube
and itunes we have a fantastic sunday
special that came out yesterday with
lewis howes we have another one that is
coming out next week with a special
guest we have not yet named
let's just suffice it to say dudes it's
a great guess it's a great guest and
you're going to want to be part of that
conversation go check it out
leave us a review at itunes we always
appreciate it it helps us with our
ranking we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
alrighty so i want to talk for a second
about holocaust remember in the states
so international holocaust remembrance
day is not yom hazikarone yamazicarone
is a holocaust memorial day it's
celebrated in israel in early may like
may 7th
international holocaust remembrance day
is sort of celebrated well commemorated
worldwide and what's amazing about the
commemorations for the holocaust
is how few people actually know jack
squat about the holocaust there's a poll
that showed that two-thirds of americans
two-thirds
did not know anything about the
holocaust particularly two-thirds of
millennials don't know
what auschwitz was which is an amazing
amazing thing i mean that's just
tremendous ignorance
of history according to a 2018 poll
two-thirds of american millennials
surveyed in a recent poll cannot
identify what auschwitz is
according to a study released on
holocaust remembrance day that found
that knowledge of the genocide that
killed six million jews during world war
ii
is not robust among american adults
twenty-two percent of millennials said
they had not heard of the holocaust or
are not sure whether they have heard of
it
that's twice the percentage of u.s
adults as a whole who said the same
only 41 percent of respondents and 66
percent of
well let's see 41 percent of respondents
and 66 two-thirds of millennials could
not come up with a correct response
identifying auschwitz as a concentration
camp
or extermination camp okay which is
uh what i love the most about this is
that millennials who apparently know the
least about the holocaust of any
generation and human
in american history are also the most
likely to call people nazis
so the same people who don't know a damn
thing about the holocaust or auschwitz
they're the same people who will say
that trump is a nazi
that i am a nazi right this is the way
that this works the less you know about
the holocaust the more you throw around
the term holocaust
as though you know what the term
holocaust means and the worse it is
and you see this from the left the left
is only interested
at least many members of the left not
all members of the left many members of
the hardcore radical left
who do not like israel and are not real
fond of jews are very fond of using the
holocaust as a reference point
in their political propaganda so let's
take for example
planned parenthood so planned parenthood
unless you forget is an organization
that slaughters some 300 000 unborn
children every year
okay they are the closest thing to a
murderous organization
in the united states right now and
planned parenthood action tweeted out
this right
on holocaust memorial day we remember
the tremendous immeasurable human cost
of bigotry
and we reaffirmed that there can be no
place for anti-semitism racism
homophobia
transphobia or any form of hatred in our
communities our politics and our country
okay this is very typical
of the intersectional left instead of
talking about the specific hatred of
jews which is what holocaust memorial
day is about or
about the dehumanization of innocence
for purposes of slaughtering them on
mass
which might undercut planned
parenthood's entire business plan
instead they sort of do this vague gloss
on the holocaust where the holocaust is
just a bad thing that happened because
of racism
the holocaust is just racism is bad
that's the lesson that we take away from
the holocaust
not that you cannot dehumanize your
political opposition not
that you should not dehumanize entire
groups of people for purposes of
murdering them
not they might want to think about
anti-semitism in its own context
as opposed to as a subset of a broader
racist
rubric instead they just cite the
holocaust as a way to
beat up on people who for example
believe in biological sex or also
believe that you shouldn't kill babies
this is how the women's march can
proclaim that it opposes bigotry
even while its leaders call for
anti-semitic boycotts against israel
from the podium at the women's march
see here's the thing about the holocaust
the more specific you get about the
holocaust
the less likely you are you are to
actually invoke it
as an as an analog as a basis of
comparison
when folks in the pro-life movement talk
about a holocaust of the unborn that's a
very specific charge
the charge is that there are groups of
people who are dehumanizing a specific
subset of humanity for purposes of
exterminating them
that's very specific when people say
everybody i don't like
is a nazi that's them taking the
holocaust and taking nazism
and then zooming out with the lens so
far
that the holocaust and nazism become
meaningless and this is very common
this is how you get people like jeremy
corbyn who's an open anti-semite
tweeting this out
jeremy corbyn is the head of the labor
party he's so anti-semitic that people
inside his own party have had to run
screaming from him
he tweeted out in memory of the millions
of jewish people and others who perished
in the holocaust
let us never allow anti-semitism or any
other form of racism to disfigure our
society
jeremy corbyn is an open anti-semite who
has backed hamas and hezbollah
he has worked with them to speak in the
parliament he's an ardent israel hater
who is associated
with characters who actually repeat the
medieval blood libel the jews
are using the blood of non-jewish
children for various purposes
he has worked with holocaust deniers in
the past and jeremy corbyn is tweeting
that out why
because for people of the radical left
the holocaust is only important so long
as you can use it as a club against your
political opponent same thing
for representative ilhan omar the
democrat from minnesota now you remember
ilhan omar
from such glorious things as tweeting
out that israel was hypnotizing the
world and may allah awaken everyone
well over the weekend she tweeted out an
adl
an adl tweet that said right-wing
extremists committed nearly every
extremist murder in 2018.
it was an older tweet from the adl and
also
that report was deeply flawed okay the
report was deeply flooded not because
right-wing extremists don't commit
murder but because
the adl's case that there was an
increase in the number of murders in the
united states is simply not true
ilhan omar tweeted out today we remember
the murder of 17 million people
including six million jews at the hands
of the nazis first of all
necessary to to point out that there's a
difference between
people who are innocent who died during
world war ii and the holocaust which was
the systemic targeting and killing
of a specific group of humans okay at
best 10 million were people
10 million people were killed in the
holocaust even that is upper end in
terms of systemic targeting
of particular groups six million people
who were jews were specifically targeted
because they had the last name that
ended in steiner berg
okay with the rise of anti-semitic and
neo-nazi ideology writes ohan omar
it's more important than ever that we
learn from the atrocities of the past
and commit to fighting intolerance
hashtag holocaust memorial yes i want to
hear from the lady who has backed
terrorists in the past
against jews and joins with people who
want boycott of israel to destroy the
only jewish country on planet earth to
talk about the holocaust
and to talk about anti-semitism it's
amazing how many folks from the left are
willing to
to use terminology they
they actively do not know anything about
or know better than to use
in order to prove in order to push their
political agenda
it truly is an astonishing thing and
shows how cynical
so many of these folks are ilhanomar and
jeremy corbin paying attention to the
hot
planned parenthood pretending they care
about the holocaust yeah give me give me
a
break give me a break okay meanwhile
meanwhile
there's this amazing thing that's
happening on twitter according to john
levine okay john levine is a media
editor over at the rap and he tweeted
this out earlier
i'm told by a person in the know that
tweeting learn to code
at any recently laid off journalist will
be treated as abusive behavior
and is a violation of twitter's terms of
service
now to to understand why this is
hilarious and ridiculous
you have to understand what's happening
so buzzfeed recently laid off a couple
hundred journalists
now i'm in the journalism business the
opinion journalism business
and i'm never happy to see journalists
laid off of any particular stripe
because i like more opinion
i like people battling it out i think
it's good for the country when we have
people battling it out
it is also true that a lot of these
enterprises expanded too fast and then
had to contract because they did not
control their growth
instead they simply hired a lot of
people on the basis of
projection projected future growth as
opposed to cash flow
and now they've had to fire a lot of
people well the irony here is that there
are a lot of folks on the left
and particularly in the the sort of
elitist
left who have been suggesting that when
people who are trump supporters lose
their jobs in small towns
that the solution is to learn to code
this has become sort of shorthand
for elitists sneering at people who are
less educated than themselves
now i've said myself listen if you're in
a dying town then
maybe the best solution is to move out
of dying town because i don't think
that the politicians are going to bring
your job back but the learn to code
point
has been something that you get from
left-leaning elitists for a long time
that when illegal immigrants come into
the country and threaten for example
the labor base that that's not a problem
because people should just learn to code
well now these journalists are being
laid off and a lot of people who are
trump supporters are going after the
journalists saying
well look you lost your job it ain't
coming back so learn to code
well john levine is now reporting that
twitter is going to ban
people for telling journalists to learn
to code
that's right our nation's bravest
firefighters the intrepid people out
there
every day bringing you the truth cannot
handle somebody telling them to learn to
code
okay yeah sure twitter that's not a
mockery of anything it's it's
no reason that that's that doesn't make
a mockery of these journalists it
doesn't make them look like
children and pansies to be very upset
about learn to code
come on it's just i love it just just
amazing you know what's what's good for
the goose is not good for the gander
in the media this is why jim acosta is
going to be writing a book about jim
acosta being a victim because jim acosta
loves jim acosta
because the members of the journalistic
community have such a picture in their
head that they are all heroic
woodward and bernstein types if somebody
tells them hey maybe you ought to get a
job for a living then they get very
upset
whereas a lot of them will tell
everybody else to get a job
for a living pretty amazing stuff okay
now i wanted to bring you an update
on the government shutdown which ended
last friday when president trump
unilaterally decided we are done here no
more government shutdown maybe we'll be
back here in three weeks
my guess is that in three weeks the
president will declare some national
emergency and then
try to activate border funding from
other parts of the defense department
but there was a poll that came out last
week that was largely ignored until just
about now
and it's pretty interesting okay there
is a
nbc wall street journal poll and here is
what this poll
showed what this poll showed is that by
popularity by popularity
who was the least popular who was the
least popular
politician during the actual shutdown
now
if you listen to the media you would
have thought it was donald trump right
it was trump
who had lost the most ground during the
government shutdown
but that is not true that is not true so
they've done sort of a before and after
the government shutdown snapshot
of poll numbers and here's what they
found the democratic party
by the end of the shutdown 35 percent of
americans were positive on the democrats
40 were negative so that means that they
were five points underwater
okay the republican party was nine
points under water 34
positive 43 negative so they had
basically the same positive rating as
the democratic party almost identical
trump was more popular than both he was
at 39
39 positive 51 percent negative which
means he was 12 points
12 points underwater mitch mcconnell was
18 points underwater
17 positive 35 percent negative
who was the most unpopular politician in
america during the government shutdown
nancy pelosi she was at 28 positive
47 percent negative so in other words
the same media
that we're cheering her you remember
seth meyers on his show saying nancy
they should build the wall out of nancy
pelosi since she's just so tough
the same media cheering nancy pelosi
shockingly we're not covering her
radical drop in popularity
they weren't covering the fact that the
government shutdown was hurting nancy
pelosi even worse than it was hurting
president trump and that media coverage
caused people to jump early in the
republican party thinking
that the damage from the government
shutdown was simply too great as i said
last week
if president trump wanted to go all the
way on the government shutdown then you
have to be willing to go all the way
there's no such thing as a good bluff in
politics you have to be willing to pull
the trigger
trump was not willing to pull the
trigger now he's going to take i think
the other way out which is the national
emergency route but it is
important to note that that headline
only came out after the shutdown ended
after the shutdown ended suddenly we are
learning that nancy pelosi in fact
was deeply unpopular with the american
people amazing
amazing how that worked just just a
shock that's not media bias though
that's that's simply they must have
missed it they must have missed it
meanwhile there's still aftermath from
the roger stone indictment last week so
roger stone as you recall
was arrested last week on charges that
he lied to the house intelligence
committee the senate intelligence
committee the fbi
over the weekend stone went off on the
fbi he was very upset at the fbi
obviously he said these are gestapo
tactics which again no they're not a
warrant and an arrest
for lying to law enforcement that's not
the gestapo
please do not make holocaust comparisons
that are completely stupid i'm 66 years
old i don't own a firearm
i have no prior criminal record my
passport has expired
the special counsel's office is well
aware of the fact that i'm represented
the idea that a 29-member swat team in
full tactical gear
with assault weapons would surround my
house
defensive shell of force to try to
depict me as public
enemy number one the og it's an attempt
to poison the jury pool
let's let's get these are gestapo
tactics let's get no they're not gestapo
tactics but
was it over the top yes now he is saying
that he may he may in fact
cooperate with robert mueller's probe he
was talking with this week
and he said that that's a question i'll
have to determine after my attorneys
have some discussion
if there's wrongdoing by other people in
the campaign that i know about which i
know of not
if there is i'd certainly testify
honestly so we'll see if there any more
shoes to drop on the roger stone
indictment as i said last week
what that indictment says to me mostly
is that there was willingness
by members of the trump campaign to get
information from wikileaks but no
evidence
of actual of actual quid pro quo's
happening between the trump campaign and
the russian government
and if you're using roger stone as a
go-between these are not high-level
contacts it's not
steve bannon or jared kushner calling up
vladimir putin and saying what can you
do for us today
okay time for some things i like and
then some things that i hate so things i
like i've been on a sports book kick
lately i just need some relaxation over
the weekends so i've been reading jeff
pearlman's books i really enjoy them
he's a good sports writer former sports
illustrated guy he has a book called the
bad guys one about the 1986 mats now i
am
a primary white sox fan but i'm a
secondary red sox fan i picked up all of
my father's sports allegiances he was a
white sox fan
for his entire life then he moved to
boston for college and he became a bit
of a red sox fan
so 86 is still painful for people who
are red sox
fans but this book is great it really
paints an interesting picture of the new
york mets
and doesn't pull any punches i mean
they're a bunch of jerks basically
and the book is really colorful and fun
it's very gossipy so if you're into
sports books
go check out the bad guys one by jeff
pearlman really been enjoying it
and it is worth the read okay time for a
couple of things that i hate
okay so tom brokaw was you know
the old guy from nbc he was on meet the
press and he started talking about
immigration
and in the middle of talking about
immigration he simply labeled all trump
supporters racists who don't like
racial intermarriage it got very weird
very quickly here was tom brokaw's
statement yeah i hear when i push people
a little harder
i don't know whether i want brown grand
babies i mean
that's also a part of it it's the
intermarriage that is going on and the
cultures
that are conflicting with each other i
also happen to believe that the
hispanics should work harder at
assimilation that's one of the things
i've been saying for a long time
you know that they ought not to be just
codified in their communities but
make sure that all their kids are
learning to speak english and that they
feel comfortable in the communities and
that's going to take outreach on both
sides frankly
okay so he was ripped up and down for
this now he said two things one of them
was
really bad right he said that trump
supporters don't want brown
grandchildren which come on that's just
absurd no one really most people don't
care
what color their grandkids are so long
as they have grandkids honestly
as far as his statement that hispanics
are not learning english fast enough
there's some mixed
mixed stuff on this okay so there's one
study that came up
in 2013 and it suggested that the
children of immigrants are learning
english as fast as the children of
immigrants have learned
english in the past according to the
washington post as of 2013
first generation mexican immigrants
still lag behind on learning english but
second generation americans including
those who live with their first
generation parents
acquire english just as fast as do asian
or european
immigrants by the third generation
virtually all hispanics in the united
states speak english
and this is reflected actually in
support for english as the official
language by racial group
74 of americans as of 2013 were
supportive of english as the official
language so we're 71 percent of blacks
70 of asians and 68 of third-generation
hispanics so you know people are
according to that data learning english
quickly
however there's other research that sort
of suggests differently according to npr
there's a study conducted by the
philadelphia education research
consortium
it looked at english learners who
entered the district as kindergarteners
in 2008
and their progress through the end of
the third grade and what it found is
that students whose home language was
spanish
were considerably less likely to reach
proficiency than any other subgroup
spanish speakers were almost half as
likely as chinese speakers to cross the
proficiency threshold so what this
suggests is that this isn't necessarily
a this isn't really a hispanic problem
what this really is is an american
problem
where we are not encouraging people to
assimilate and in places like california
we're engaging in bilingual education
right you should not be engaging in
bilingual education
when my ancestors got here they did not
go to schools where they were taught
yiddish and english they went to schools
where they were taught english
even if they spoke yiddish at home the
multicultural attempt to break people
down into separate communities
is really a problem and pretending that
there are not cultural differences
between people who have assimilated and
people who have not assimilated
is of course very silly so i think some
of the ire for for tom brokaw is earned
i think some of the ire is an attempt to
avoid some
real questions about how particular
education system in the united states
works okay other things that i hate dan
savage who's just a sleazeball
dan savage was on bill maher's show
you'll remember him from such things
as he leads some sort of anti-bullying
crusade even though he is
a massive bully dan savage right this is
a guy who wrote for i believe was salon
back in 2000
that he hated gary bauer so much that he
he volunteered for gary bauer's
presidential campaign
and then had the flu and licked
doorknobs around the office
in order to give other people on the
campaign the flu i mean dan savage is a
vile hateful person
here is dan savage though suggesting
that all trump supporters are racist
white bleeps
they're good at demagoguery they're good
at racism they're good at stoking fear
all this stuff everybody's like oh it's
economic anxiety oh it's the working
class all those first reactions to
trump's wins
all the research all the social science
research and data cents have proven that
it's
racist white dumb and amazing
in our anti-democratic system if this is
how democrats want to see it they will
lose
i mean if they really want to alienate
everybody in the middle of the country
by calling them racist white dumb bleeps
keep going with that keep going that'll
get a lot of applause in places like los
angeles
but it ain't going to get you a lot of
applause in places that you need to win
in the middle of the country if you want
to have a shot in georgia you probably
shouldn't be calling people racist white
bleeps
for considering the possibility of
voting for donald trump now maybe
look the worst case scenario here is
that trump has been so off-putting in
his years in office that he actually
alienates the american people into
voting
for an open radical an open socialist
that would be a disaster
but if democrats continue with this
theme
that everybody who doesn't think like
them is a racist evil person
then america is not only irrevocably
broken but democrats
i think will have a worse shot at
winning election you can't
you can't just insult americans you
can't insult your way into the white
house
you can insult other candidates into the
white house donald trump did that you
can't insult
the american people into the white house
it just doesn't work that way all right
we will be back here later today we have
two more live hours coming up later
which is why you should subscribe
because there's so many goodies if
you're not subscribing you're missing
out go check it out
we'll see you here tomorrow if not i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
senja villarreal executive producer
jeremy boring
senior producer jonathan hay our
supervising producer is mathis glover
and our technical producer is austin
stevens edited by adam sayawitz audio is
mixed by mike caromina hair and makeup
is by jessua olvera production assistant
nick sheehan the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2019